I don't want to out you but tell your
audience what you told me about Bernie
Sanders because you know how popular he
isn't you know how unpopular it will be
for you to tell your audience this
because there's this huge contingent
well that said he's just another filthy
commie who wants to take everyone's
stuff that's all I have the message on
Twitter
back by popular demand for those
listening terrestrially you need to
check out his youtube channel or you
just google sargon of a CAD he's the
first search result now we have Milo
taken over Nero
we have this guy taken over sorry it's
crazy it's crazy talks are gone
do you still go by the pseudonym or do I
use your real name you know I really
don't mind a lot of people use the
pseudonym just because it's easier by I
don't mind my name's Karl or you come
Sargon I do not mind but Karl you have
to admit it's like it's kind of a funny
name for someone as sort of dominating
as you are as a Type A personality Karl
a Type A personality oh what's that I
don't know your beard and your your your
your anti feminism
you know your oppressive just like you
know patriotic new world leader
Karl yeah well you know Karl is actually
always when I started stand-up and it's
just bled into the show whenever I would
do an imaginary character I would always
use Karl because for some reason it
would elicit a laugh it would just be
like all right Karl you know and it'd be
like Jesus yelling at Karl or something
it's just kind of the quintessential
name I think of the unicorn from YouTube
Karl unicorn he needs the Union seek the
kidney this is candy red house Charlie
Charlie there's a Karl in there
somewhere
I don't think there is a Colin Charlie
are basically the same one not gay Jared
doesn't know what he's talking about
I nearly he wakes up at 10 o'clock and
calls me and my iPad broke alright so a
lot has happened since you were last on
so last you were honoree we went for
like four hours we talked about feminism
you were kind of new to me as far as I
was coming across your content more and
I said I have to have this guy on and
you were talking about we were sort of
talking about police brutality but that
was before the black lives matter really
picked up and Mitsu because I remember
you were kind of making the case that
you understand we both said yeah we can
definitely be there some cops go out
there who are poor out of line has your
perspective changed a little bit since
they've gone full bore and black lives
matter has become just so corrosive to
the campus experience
I don't not to lead you yeah no no it's
nice fine um
okay so I I still I mean that you know
that it's it's not that you know there
is still obviously and I'm judging from
an outsider perspective sure I think
there's still obviously certain problems
internal problems with certain police
forces in America but nothing is you
know this is this is one of the things
always I always know even I have to talk
about these little things because you
always got to say well it's not every
single individual one anything why do I
even have to make that distinction right
oh like gay guys can be really annoying
yeah exactly but that doesn't mean every
single one you know general rule the
thing it's there's definitely still a
problem but the black lives matter folks
really I'm not helping themselves
they're definitely oh my god they've
definitely ruined their own PR just
they're just busy peeing in their own
bathtub I just don't understand what
they're doing or why they're doing well
Mitsu was so bad and I talked about this
on air because you're a reasonable
person I'd like to think of myself as a
reasonable person and like that we both
conceded like yeah there's some of this
that's going on I think last time we
spoke I leaned more toward there
exaggerating and I err on the side of
not all cops or as bad as I think and
you should have aired on the other side
and now we're probably both closer
toward the middle yeah probably but I
think if you read the straight wasn't me
too was a print Princeton Princeton
where they went into the library where
kids were studying yeah and one of them
said f you and ever you and your white
tee is f your white tee is your white
tears bring me joy and I was sitting
there as gone okay the girls crying
black girls yelling this what she didn't
understand that girl and this is
reflective of course of the entire
country what that black lives matter did
to that white girl was made her
boyfriend next to her a racist for the
rest of his life for a lot of cases he
sees a girl who is sitting studying in a
library she's crying and it's a
sociopathic no empathy for this girl
who's crying and you just start that guy
who probably maybe never had a shred of
em everyone has a shred of it probably
wasn't a racist
I guarantee became more racist and I
will tell you this the feedback we've
gotten since a lot of them
I don't know about you but I get
concerned with the pendulum going too
far the other way because I think people
have rejected all of it and become a
little bit more hostile well I noticed
this you guys had Martin Luther King Day
in America recently yes and he's I mean
what just the gone blue no no that's
okay it's just jared is slacking okay
it's it's the eternal thing isn't it
like what what what did math what was
supposed his littler thing is I would I
would like people to be judged by the
content of the character rather than the
color of their skin as you know it's
it's not in any way any kind of extreme
revolutionary sentiment except the black
lives matter folks are going completely
against that they're completely
antithetical everything that he was
saying that right he doesn't want people
judged on the color of their skin and I
mean they literally consoles black lives
matter they think yeah the gates well
the Oscars so white they're boycotting
it now it's like listen there I can't
think of many great performances this
year period I know I know I mean I've
seen nearly everything I get all the
screeners can you think of any like
black performances that you would put up
there I mean with Denzel Malcolm's like
it's training day it was clear like this
year what are you going for a Tyler
Perry sitcom to movie at that because
Will Smith was in a serious movie where
he had an axe and then up Oh concussed
did you see that yet I heard it's bad
I've heard it I guess you watch a lot of
films I'll be honest I'm lazy and I'm
really cynical as well how are you too
lazy to sit I'm too impatient to sit
through the crap that's the plaids true
you know I'm just
I honestly you see so many really
exciting trailers you know I can growl
go see that and then the movie is just
really really really subpar you know
where the what other sort of modern I
don't know demolition man's or
Abed Wesley smash went to jail for you
it's for taxing film was Pressy
absolutely Presley I don't even remember
debt it was some kind of it was a
time-traveling kind of they got frozen
and they get woken up in PC heaven I
know what everyone is afraid violence
they don't swear they're gonna meet
everything is you know the testosterone
has been drained out of society the
juice is gone and then you have like
Sylvester Stallone huge hulking guy
right a huge heart he's like five six I
wouldn't say he's also about five six
across no he's not
we actually had G of Planet Hollywood in
the UK at all no you've never been there
it's like it's one of those things like
you know the food's okay but you go in
and every Planet Hollywood has
designated sort of film memorabilia and
so Montreal was a little bit late on the
trend so we were like we got Stallone's
Judge Dredd costume people it was so
small you could fit it in your back
pocket like not yeah he's not he just
really lean he's uh yeah the camera can
trick you that way like Tom Hardy's what
five eight if I'm ya 589 you know this
is a guy playing Bane so it's it's all a
parlor trick up but I'm wondering like
to MLK point that's a good point
yeah so I'm one of those people that
there are a lot of people who are
imperfect and maybe aren't necessarily
overall good people but who had good
ideas and I think it was sort of a
widely accepted truce with Martin Luther
King jr. that even conservatives just
okay we're not gonna bring up his serial
philandering or as doping because he had
good ideas that we can all agree with
let's focus on the ideas that's gone now
because black lives matter push it so
hard for the first time people were
giving me guff for posting you know
quotes from MLK like a dope fiend Jeter
and it's like well we knew it but we
kind of just didn't talk about it so
again the pendulum is going the other
way that's really bizarre because I mean
in the UK would currently having this
there's a hashtag called roads must fall
I'm sure that I mean a you know you can
Google sessile drones if you won't see a
litany of his crimes but what he wasn't
you know he was a product of his time he
was an imperialist who's colonialist
right so he wasn't um you know he wasn't
the sort of person who morally in the
modern day stands up very well to
scrutiny sure but I mean did do some
things and one of the things that he did
was
with his fortune I established a college
or something and so what they did is
they set up a statue of him at this
college that he established that he felt
any fun financed because that's what
they used to do to read famous figures
who were also philanthropic and now they
want to remove the statue because of he
because of the fact that you know a man
of his time and it was acceptable to be
a racist imperialist colonialist
right and now they're like well no
that's a terrible thing so yeah we all
agree that's a terrible thing but this
is a part of history now you know it's
and I tell you I'm actually genuinely
quite worried about this kind of
iconoclasm because you see it whenever
you get a great intellectual revolution
throughout history you always see
exactly the same thing I mean if you go
back to like I think it's about 1300 BC
you have this guy called arc and answers
an Egyptian pharaoh and the Egyptian you
know they've got Pantheon they've got
them rather Sun God they've got a sort
of art in the disk itself another sort
thing and this guy turn around said
rocky I've decided that there's only one
God and it's the Sun and every other God
doesn't exist so now what I'm gonna do
is find all the priests all the all the
temples I'm just gonna carve their name
off of this thing it's all gonna have to
go because it's all wrong and when you
have to say like Christianity became the
official religion of the Roman Empire
mhm what you would see is Christian
Christian mobs of radical Christians
running around pagan temples defacing
them smashing them up carving crosses in
the heads of like Nero statues where
they're raping swedish women on trains
nearly not quite yet okay sorry go ahead
you know the inferior past what's come
before isn't you know living up to our
standards now why would it what was it
that we had in the States they wanted to
remove that was a big black lives matter
thing I'm trying to remember remember
the the statue the monument who was it
oh gosh someone who was in the KKK or at
some point you yeah and I remember
sitting there like well hold on a second
someone was in the KKK Robert Byrd was
fourth in line for the Obama presidency
if a plane went down until 2000 was a
2010 till he died this guy had Klan
Dental and a company car like he was
recruiting for the KKK now on the huge
the end
on national television repeatedly in its
context racist context like in 2004 but
of course that's the politics they
absolve them of that they do that was
the founding fathers a lot too you know
whether it's Jefferson or washing they
go well they had slaves even though if
you read private writings were a lot of
them are saying this is reprehensible
and eventually this is going to have to
change like you said there people are
flawed right but I feel as though now
both sides especially with MLK was it
was very it was kind of startling to me
to see a lot of because a lot of
conservatives wanted to claim him as a
Republican which isn't entirely accurate
and then Democrats wanted to claim him
as a Democratic Socialist which is not
accurate but they competed over the
ideas and then this time it was just
like matter and then there was a bomb
it's really bizarre I mean like there's
no honestly I mean I I can't I don't see
the argument against people being judged
by characteristics they personally can
choose and control I mean know who would
really want to be judged on arbitrary
characteristics you know you wouldn't
want to be chose on the color of your
hair would you you know you wouldn't
want to be judged on with your left or
right handed why would you want to be
judged on the color of your skin or
anything like this it's ridiculous
you've got no control over it and so you
know what I what is the argument for
doing this well I wouldn't want to be
judged on my inability to grow a beard
as you can good Carl but no you're well
again you lose power right if you say
it's something you can control
then you at some point oh we have to go
to breaks and you know the whole idea
now the self help us relinquish control
and you'll be happier there's some truth
to that but sometimes you have to own up
to your stuff whether you're black or
white and I think that would be
accepting some form of control and going
man maybe you're just a deadbeat because
the black guy next to you is finally
successful he's president you're a loser
there is there's definitely a degree of
learned helplessness and I do think a
lot of it comes from the Democratic
Party your country I this is the nerve
the person who'd vote Democrats so just
so you know still I'm still a dirty
liberal
we'll bring him on after the break
because little-known facts he's not as
liberal as he thinks are gone of a CAD
ladder with Cotter stay tuned we're back
sargon of akkad just google him and you
will find him first before any actual
historical figure so you say you're a
liberal I have a bone to pick with you
here I don't want to out you but tell
your audience what you told me about
Bernie Sanders because you know how
popular he isn't you know how unpopular
it will be for you to tell your audience
this because there's this huge
contingent said he's just another filthy
commie who wants to take everyone's
stuff drug you were drunk complete it it
was cider and cigars I don't think he's
a communist because the thing is to be
an actual communist you've got to be
some sort of crazy radical
me me you know there's there's a
difference between a ninety percent yeah
even a so she even like a democratic
socialist in a communist but that was
the point in my point is I definitely
have seen it whether it's people like
you or Joe Rogan people out there who
are anti-authoritarian and I know that
you know full well that the economic
authoritarianism is still
authoritarianism who avoid that topic
because he's so popular online and I and
I've spoken with some people behind the
scenes were like yeah I agree with you
but he is like he's like the new Ron
Paul where if you say anything yeah
people loving as far as if you say
anything his hordes of followers come
over like we did that video on Bernie
Sanders there is I'm a comedian but
there are 35 references including Bernie
Sanders himself people can go too loud
or with credit calm including HuffPo all
the site's substantiating it and then
third party analysis of course with the
Wall Street Journal and conservative
comments 35 like we didn't just just do
a hatchet job and there's like you just
you're just paid by Big Pharma well okay
this is this is actually really
interesting I've literally just finished
a video on Hillary Clinton yeah and it's
not as um it's not as much the tangent
as you think
because I'm very much you know I hate
the Young Turks I I really hate Young
Turks and it's not because I think
they're wrong it's because they're
idiots but they have got one good point
and that's follow the money you know
that with the whole Wolf Pack thing try
to get their money out of politics and
they're absolutely right because Bernie
Sanders if you look at who backs Bernie
Sanders it's mostly public donations or
unions and so I mean you can tell at
least yeah but who has more money than
anyone in politics combined I'm sure it
is the union's anyons has 18 out of the
top 20 donors or unions Koch brothers
not even close
I've got no doubt but the thing is it's
more about what what direction it's
going to push them in for me that's
important okay yeah sure ease unions and
he gets a lot of donations from the
general public as well sure um it's not
the most terrible thing in the world I
mean unions are a hurdle for big
business but the I mean at the moment
coming you can't say the big business
doesn't need a few hurdles you know I
think they certainly need less hurdles
but not really yes like okay let me give
you a good example did you see the big
short no okay this isn't as much of a
tangent as you think but we're just
watching it yesterday you know it's
about the housing market and the
collapse and the financial collapse
right and so if you watch this film this
is a great example I think it's really
easy to believe that it's deregulation
and there's no regulation of businesses
but if you look at the business the
industries where people are least
satisfied Airlines health care energy
those are the most regulated businesses
in the world and yet the problem isn't
actually there's no regulation the
problem is the regulation is in the
wrong places well I believe it's too
much regulation and it's almost always
regulation that favors the government so
a good example is the Big Short so watch
this and they were talking about you
know the remember this term subprime I
don't know in the UK
okay so subprime it actually didn't have
the same funnily enough in Canada we
didn't we didn't have the housing bubble
because they acted much more
conservatively with their government
then I don't know about the UK but they
didn't do the subprime mortgages so I
don't think we did I don't think we did
either I'd have to check but at least it
wasn't something that was a big deal of
it right so for those people who don't
fully understand it again it's kind of
complicated and the Big Short
deliberately makes it more
complicated subprime was basically you
have no business being in that house but
you're getting a mortgage anyway you're
not you're putting 5% down your credit
score is 550 and you're getting a
$400,000 house right this is house you
can't afford you can't afford Gregg so
you watch this whole film Big Short and
it shows about predatory lending was a
term that was thrown right and I say
this because this is the single big this
is the Bernie Sanders argument it's all
about big banks so by the way gave more
to Obama than McCain of Romney a
particular Goldman Sachs so Oh like that
Clinton now yeah
well they're just hedging during the
business of hedging their bets that's
what they're betting that's what they do
so we can all agree on that and by the
way the tea party started with Rick
Santelli and a rant against the bailout
of the big banks so we did it before the
occupiers conservatives never supported
the idea of a big dog and I get that
happened under Bush not a conservative
back to Big Short they talk about
predatory lending and they show these
banks and they're talking about how
they're basically packaging mortgages to
make greater profits and gonna work even
to these people there's no you know this
is a stripper who's has a credit score
of 520 and there's no way she can pay
back at no point do they mention Fannie
Mae Freddie Mac which basically was the
reason for this right banks were
pressured into and basically the name of
sort of economic equality was a big
portion but the government guaranteed
these loans saying hey you can't be mean
and not let this family have a home it's
the bedrock of the economy everyone
deserves a home so logically you go well
hold on a second predatory lending why
would a bank lend a loan to someone who
they knew had no possibility of even
paying it back Bernie Sanders Big Short
all of Hollywood all of the young they
make it seem like banks or just mean but
it doesn't pass the economic smell test
it was big government and
over-regulation and getting involved and
encouraging and guaranteeing these loans
the point where banks are going okay all
right we'll take the money and they knew
they would get the bailout at the end of
it which is another big government
regulatory policy that's my yeah okay
yeah now I agree with you that's okay
the the issue that I have is not that
government is bad right government isn't
inherently bad it's not inherently good
is just a tool that people can use and
I think the problem is really
demonstrated by the fact that I mean it
like you say right the the the Goldman
Sachs Koch brothers they all gave huge
amounts of money to Hillary Clinton
Barack Obama and if you wonder who the
Republicans are funded by it's oil money
and so you know Jeb Bush mostly funded
by we are in terrestrial but we have to
go to a break soon right all right we
have your johor will do the web extended
version so your people can get this
whole context where we have 30 seconds
all right so listen sargon of akkad
youtube channel you want to hear the
extended version or watch the video
stream go to la tour with credit comm
because now he's gonna go off the rails
I believe say 9/11 was an inside job web
extended version subscribe by clicking
my face or the button above me or one of
these videos next to me it's all free if
you don't like it I can take off my
glasses I can be whoever you want me to
be
okay internet love me I need your
affection what are the latest polls